[BLANK_AUDIO]
Just like accents, different accents
if you go from the East Coast,
there's an accent, a different way
of saying things to the West Coast.
I think in different families,
the language could very quite a bit,
but I think in general, I mean just like
the Southern, the Central, the Northern,
and they are all very similar in their
pronunciations like I would say looty.
And it's a sound with the tongue on
the back of the teeth with your T.
But there are three different ways
to pronounce the T in the language.
You can do a hard T, a soft T, or
an extended T, and depending on
how you pronounce it could vary.
I think it would make sense for
the coastal Miwok region plains, lake,
any region of the Miwok to create their
own app, language app if the need is